You guys look where I am right now
Yeah, first of all, hi you guys may know Marquez MKBHD,  you're so awesome
And I can't believe that I'm sitting here right now. Well, thank you I appreciate that. This is so exciting im about to eat some cheese
We're trying to figure out what video to do and I've been kind of like asking people about what their oldest piece of tech that
They had and you said you have your first smartphone here I do
So this when I first got actually too smart not even my first phone
This is the first oldest phone I've ever had nokia
3310 came out in 2000 first smartphone I ever had was the Motorola Droid
But then we found something that came out the same year that this did and maybe a little more relevant to Justine's channel
I don't I don't I don't even know. Are you sure are you sure about this totally confident that this will be an interesting?
Exciting unboxing I'm already freaking out. I think this is the original tape. This is the iBook
So this is the clamshell one and this was shipped
September
26 year 2000 so it's an 18 year old piece of tech, but still unopened
I don't know what happens when you ship something like this does the battery corrode? I don't know what happens
Maybe it's gonna be perfectly fine. This tape has never been
Touched this is great. Where did you get this this?
uh
I have a friend at red who?
Used to work at a company a long time ago had a bunch of tech from there
Apparently had a room with a bunch of these in it you said hey, do you want one I said yes, here it is
I can't believe this you, okay,  are you 100% sure I mean are you SURE, yes
Here are the specs , cause that's Maybe the best part 300 megahertz
PowerPC GT processor half a megabyte of cache on that chip 64 megabytes of storage
six
gigabyte hard disk, aww that's so cute
So Oh, so 64 Meg's of RAM Wow about six gigs of hard drive. Had a cd-rom drive. Do you remember that?
I do I do it wasn't even that long ago optional wireless airport card
I wonder if this has it optional Wi-Fi
But it has a built-in Ethernet Jack six hour battery quick and easy internet access includes 30 day free internet access
Microsoft Internet Explorer Oh
Outlook Express and Netscape communicator. Do you remember?
Netscape communicator that's something I don't remember Oh Mac OS pre-installed. That's really considerate. That's good
Here we go, I don't know if I want it
I do want to i'll cut half of it then you cut the other half
Okay, we have a power strip in case you want to plug it in, cause I have a feeling It's not still charged. You think? I don't think.
Okay I cut half , there you go.
Lets finish the job
My heart. seals broken, seals broken
I Can't believe what's happening right now. Cause, this is this is monumental. This is 18 years. Oh, it's upside down, oh okay ya. That's okay , alright.
Mean this box is in a really good condition. Yes, surprisingly not yellow
So this in a 2000 the whole thing comes up. I think I got my first
Geez whoa wait, is it a tangerine one?
Must be I'm so confused. Why is there a box inside of the box? Oh, no, it's not. What's this?
This is the accessories probably the charger. Yes all that fun stuff
why, why is that in tangerine?
I dont know, That's Weird.
Well all right. Should we just... getting further. This is crazy. Look at this
This doesn't really look like a very Apple way to pack things show that like this, kinda like...
You're curious what stuff shipped like? Oh don't drop it
That would be something I would do
Doesn't look very Apple-ish.
That's okay we'll just, Ill hold the box now.
Tadaa, its so beautiful.
I Never had one of these ,this remind you of Mickey Mouse at all?
Kinda reminds of lil android
oh ya
This looks beautiful
I have been researching actually because I've wanted to get all of the colors to find one of these that has never been opened before, that's pretty crazy.
How many colors were there cuz I see tangerine here. There's tangerine blueberry. Yeah, graphite indigo and key lime
The key lime was the online exclusive
This is still sealed too. The use of the materials in closed media as subject to terms presented for acceptance during the installation of any
Printed blah blah blah blah by opening this you agree to all such printed terms. We agree. Where's the knife? Let's do it
Alright, I don't even get it
Like this is a weird color, it's just I feel like this just doesn't look like a good design. In 2018
It doesn't but I brought this back to the year 2000. I think we might think other wow, that's the mouse.
WOW
I think
That's not the power there is no no. Oh, it's a laptop. There's no mouse No, that's right. This is the power. This is power...
What?
Look at this
Oh that's a little sticky. I am now thinking back to like what it was like when these
It's like I mean the iMac really changed everything iMac is one of those
machines that I remember
Basically when I was in I think it was like fifth grade
Where the teacher had one in the back of the class and if you were a good kid
You got to use it sometimes play some
Solitaire or whatever you were into. Oh
This is still sealed
Oh I didn't want to rip it, but I ripped it so
How many new people are out there they'd have rooms of things that they don't have
opened a room of
Yeah, just this is a great color
Speaking of, We were just talking about colored gadgets and coloured iPhone's on the other video. This is nice
This is better-looking in person than in the photo. This is actually really much better looking
we did an ask video on your channel, and we're talking about iPhone colors
And what's crazy is they had all of these color choices and these are computers. They don't phones
These were extremely expensive devices.What happened to you Apple? These are nice. You should bring this back. This is a different blue than this
Oh and it has this when you open it like new laptops when you open them to have the little thing on the screen
I'm almost I'm pumped to see the screen because this is 18 year old display
Okay, I mean all of the ones that I've seen on eBay like it's all discolored they have a lot of cracking
Oh, that's cracked. That is cracked
But it's got a handle it does have a handle what a great idea
This is so early in the days of laptops that you had to make sure people knew that they could bring it places
Yeah
so the first laptops had these handles here are like briefcase like almost and this is probably closer to a purse type of thing, but i thnk
Bring it places. If they brought the handle back I would be mad about it.
Well now I got these sleeves, oh the sleeves true this is cracked see
That was a very common problem actually
so thats
This is in such incredible condition, like I'm going to... I'm Going to pass out.
there's a lot of really interesting aesthetic things about this computer ,the keys
You can sort of see through the keyboard to see the switches
It's an apple keyboard for sure. It's kinda nice. Yeah, nice
Every key is concave and then I was looking for speakers. I don't think there's any up here
It's just this single circle all the ports
There's a headphone some ports never die, that's true except apparently until 2018, but you got to have fun
With it dying. Yeah, at first I was kind of mad
But I got my first phone with no headphone and I was just kind of forced into being okay with it
So I have wireless headphones now. I'm okay. We're okay. It'll be all right, but this is back in the glory days
And then oh, man
Over here we're looking at you have your modem you ever Ethernet and then you have one single full-size USB port?
One like what are you supposed to do with that plug in your mouse?
Technically today's laptops are throwback. That's true. And then this is your speaker output
So you have a headphone jack on once we know that's the power. Oh, I thought that folks. That's easy. That's the headphone jack
There's no mic input. That's the power cable. What is
This I actually really like this. Yeah, he wasn't aware that that's how the power cable worked
It's actually a really cool idea I guess so apples always had a sort of a smart idea as far as power cables
MagSafe was one of my favorites ever I
Really miss it. All right? I'm reckless. Oh and it's just plugs into the top
Trying to boot it before plugging in there's no way I mean if this has battery then I
Break it and it just goes really really far back. Well plugged in you Justine are pressing the power button
Looks like an air pod. It's no MagSafe, but
It lit up a
little green glowing
Circle I think that means it's time to press the button. I don't you I don't know about you, but I'm ready. Okay?
hard drives this
Mac os9 holy moly. You can see in its Bryton everything. Oh
Oh my god
oh and also feel the this the click eNOS is kind of
Cuz I went like this like expecting it to click is not the worst touch trackpad, obviously
Oh my gosh, all the plugins the control panel. Holy crap. I'm losing my freaking mind
It doesn't seem to have any problems at all. No, just me turn it off
No, no in dark. The mouse is still here
I think it's playing like a little like the the intro welcome to your computer for the first time ever. Oh wow
get hyped I
Just wanna see you freak out one day. What is going on about something? Oh, this is the first boot like welcome Cassie
The continue button this is kind of way
I'm getting like such a throwback because I
Was going into college when these sort of started coming out and I went to school for graphic design
So a lot of my design I was like mimicking from this like interface. This is not I'm gonna quit okay
If there is this register you register your product. Can I skip that?
Who's it gonna send this information to whatever else I mean novel has my entire life
I can see from here literally every single pixel, but that's fine. Where will you primarily use this computer?
At school college or government government and then what describes you best?
Design publishing. Yeah. Sure. Yes me all about that. Graphite one in the middle. It looks good. I'm all about it
You had your email in there? So you just sent a registration here. I've look Cisco. Oh, it's not gonna connected to the Internet
Oh, that's true. Do you want to get on the Internet? Yes. I wonder for Internet trial. I'll use my existing internet
Tell me more about the Internet
The Internet is a worldwide network of computers that you can access using your computer and a telephone line
It's simple to continue about the Internet. Yeah
It's just people who are on the internet they talk to you. Can you imagine being what have we stopped with the
Iconic some more about the internet. This is probably a lot of people's first machine that ever connected to the Internet
Yeah
Considering how long this tutorial is when you want to browse the web or send and receive email your computer dials your ISP
And it connects to the internet. Usually it's a local phone call. So write in the comments below
Let me know how old you guys were in
2000 you're gonna be mad at how many people say they weren't born yet. I know it's actually shocking
Yeah, I've had a Mac my entire life from the beginning like our first one that we had
It was like the original Mac. It was the one megabyte version the Power Mac g4 was my first computer
That's what I took my senior picture with I instead of buying a car when I turned 16
I spent all of my money on this classroom. I had had this color IMAX. This is a long tutorial
Yeah, Wow, they really don't want us messing around
World book is World Book Encyclopedia?
Yeah, I used to just read it because I had nothing else on my computer except the world book trial
Oh now we're in an email tutorial. This is intense. Oh, he's an exit button. Should I just exit?
I think we're gonna get the point. Yeah
Area network
Yeah, I used to go to land parties because we didn't have internet like we did not have internet that we could actually play games
with each other so we need to bring our computers to each others house something that sit next to each other and maybe
Chosen Mountain Dew and a pizza and it was it was a time to be alive
Or the shirt for a reason the the Apple logo up in the corner is your classic Apple rainbow logo?
I'm gonna have to do some research and insert some fun facts for you guys here. Okay, the launcher down here
I completely forgot about that. Yeah, that is pretty intense. I keep wanting to for such. Oh
Wow tinnie
Gosh, do you invert ICQ?
My time, I didn't even have the oil Instant Messenger. I still remember my ICQ number
Let's try it. This thing's gonna turn to a 2018 MacBook Pro I plug it into
the suspense
I'm figuring your system. This will only take a moment. I
feel like a moment back in 2000 was a lot longer than
You're going online. It says okay if you have questions or get stuck
You can always refer to these twirls and how about you click connect connect?
Explore look at this, uh
Security film you try a different website. I think my first website that I ever went to is nintendo.com. Oh my gosh, something's happening
Online kinda it's loading
Well because this is such an old browser that there's no way that this is really really supported. Well
google, or is this just like a cached version because
That's working it's working that's working do we try to watch a youtube video there's no way it's gonna work
I mean what also gonna do. I don't know. Oh my gosh Netscape communicator. This was an upgrade from navigator
Look at the forth quit. Oh my gosh
Do you guys remember this probably not because some of you were born yet you I remember this
It works so keycaps, I have a very fond memory. So this was a keyboard that
My mom wouldn't she would ground me?
If I didn't get at least A's or B's and if I got a C she would take my computer away for nine weeks
Until the next report card. She used to take the keyboard and the mouse, but I had an extra mouse
so what I would do is I meet my computer up when she was gone and I would use key caps to chat with my
Friends, cuz I would just chat on he caps coffee. She's not watching this, but that's actually brilliant
She knows I told her like many years later and she caught me
So then she got smart and then just like had to put a lock on him
I'm the actual desk that the computer is in no printer attached to you right unfortunate
All your application. Oh boy. It's gonna take forever to search. Oh
Yeah hard drive, oh my got a senior officer you put in world look yeah, there it is
CD drive pops right out
yeah, and
Then get this sound probably
whoa
It's happening
That's
So Wow, nostalgia Oh, wow. Look at this. Oh my gosh. I remember these things Jesus. This is crazy
all these
Transparent elements. You can see through the CD don't want to shake it up too much with the CD
Uh-huh, but all the screws and stuff you get the vent up top. Oh did install
and then no webcam at the top just says iBook ideas, maybe Oh,
Installation was successful. That's a good sound. Okay. Let's open it up and learn now
This is still gonna be the world look from mm. What's learn about bees
Well, what is happening right now
I thought the CD sound with this. No the sound that plays when you look for bees, that's awesome
That's that's pretty good really insane what other animal sounds would a play if I looked up that animal
Course right now. Is it gonna nag me baby? Oh
Wow
Well, I know what you're gonna do in your free time now
Things make wait, this is the test. What does the Fox say?
There's no sound at the top not even worldbook
Mm knows what the Fox is. I mean we were still asking ourselves what the Fox said in what year was that?
That was 2000. There are 13 Tina
We didn't know in 2000 and we still don't know today I don't even know what else we can do with this
I mean we got on the Internet
You're now registered for a 2008. I want to get an email at some point of like thank you for registering for Netscape communicator
Welcome to the Internet. I'm still it. I'm really happy that it worked right away
This is plugged in in case you missed it straight to our router here in the studio
So it's definitely pumping way more than this was expecting
Well, thank you so much because this was such a special throwback moment like this. I didn't cry. So that's good
I did make it through this whole video, but I probably will cry when I'm editing it
But this was so awesome. The logo on the back is upside down. I flipped it over. Yes. I was like a huge thing with
It when you're out in the coffee shop people would know you have a Mac because I wanna be right side up
Make sure you guys go check out the video. We did in his channel
I'll put a link in the description and be sure to subscribe and go check out a channel if you have it already
Which I'm sure many of you have this was so awesome. Thank you so much. I'm
Super happy to be a part of it. Thanks for having me. Thank you. Okay. Bye guys